[Musique]
si papa noël quand tu descendras du ciel
avec mes jouets par milliers
n'oublie pas mes petits souliers
il fut un temps où j'ai cru à vous êtes
là et vous alors vous y croyez toujours
lui dit la vérité je sais qu'il n'existe
pas je suis vacciné c'est pourtant
chouette les fêtes de noël dans la vie
il ya plein de gens 26 magasins sont
tous du corps et il ya plein de jouets
même plus que d'habitude on commence
bien avant à recevoir les catalogues de
jouets pour en chercher et l'envoyer au
père noël
oui c'était chouette tout ça mais cette
magie a pris un sacré coup lens que je
suis la vérité vous voulez savoir
comment
bon c'est parti ça se fait pas passer
tout de suite il m'a fallu environ deux
ans pour me rendre compte que quelque
chose clochait
d'abord j'ai commencé à vous poser des
questions lorsque je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait plusieurs père noël
dans les villes dans le magasin certains
avec l'univers le blanche ne sera avec
une barbe marron certains de grande
taille
d'autres de petite taille sont assez
gros certains fins avec ou sans lunettes
fallait bien sentir modèle pays quand
même les habits je ne sais pas moi mais
ça sautait aux yeux toutes ces
différences en plus quand je suis parti
chez ma tante et mon crâne taille avec
ma famille le père noël est venu nous
apporter un cadeau
ça m'apparaît déjà étrange qu'il nous
parlait comme taillan il se trouve qu il
va rencontrer ne parlait qu'en français
les parents m'avaient expliqué krit et
qui changer de pays
il ne parlait plus que dans la langue du
pays où ils se trouvaient ce texte rendu
mer séparant qu'ils ont une réponse à
tous vous ne trouvez pas j'étais très
heureuse pour les cadeaux que j'ai reçu
et je fais 5 1 et en même temps j'ai
touché sa barbe et quand il est parti
j'ai dit à mon papa papa je trouve que
la partie du puzzle
il faut s' il m'a répondu un bon comme
cela vers l'air comme s'ils avaient
l'air étonné je n'ai jamais joué par
avec une tête pareil je me crois ça
chantait pas mon judo après ça alcool ni
tu m'as dit ma maman m'a avoué que le
père noël n'existait pas alors je suis
allée format n'est pas le questionner et
l'obligent y ait ahmed aboul gheit et
ils sont bien malin ses parents mais ils
oublient qu'on la prend vite de même
j'ai pris un art très sérieux et lui dit
c'est bon maman j'ai grandi je suis plus
un bébé qui peut me faire confiance
me dire la vérité et comme elle ne l'a
fait pas une miette
je me suis énervé et j'ai dit c'est bon
je sais le père noël n'existe pas bon
après l'histoire de pain du père noël je
pourrais vous parler de tien la petite
forêt j'ai toujours eu peur qu'on
m'arrache qu'on m'arrache aidants et
j'avais pour habitude de préparer pour
la souris une un site avec du fromage
que je mette à côté nous nous rayer avec
un matin et un mot de remerciement
je reste t il quand même longtemps élevé
à 20 musées pour le si de la rencontrer
mais à chaque fois je m'endormais le
matin voyant que la dent le mot de
remerciement et le morceau de fromage a
disparu chercher vite sous l'oreille
pour voir combien le mal est fait un
jour j'ai réussi tout c'est la magie
d'incisives j'étais très fier de moi je
vous montrais ça ma mère et comme
j'étais dans la salle de bain j'ai voulu
me laver et plus elle est tombée dans le
trou qui mène jusqu'aux ego coumans la
petite souris alem les fédés dans des
sous il n'y avait plus de dents
des jours plus tard rien ne s'est pas à
un soir ça c'est ce poids je me
dirigeais vers mon lit avec un morceau
de fromage
yamoo des excuses j'étais resté
longtemps dans mon lit et jouer
tranquillement jusqu'à un moment donné
où la porte de ma chambre c'est tout
vert je faisais semblant de dormir les
yeux entrouverts on dirait trois films
devant vous trouvez pas non bon et je
vois nahd mère s'approcher du lit vous
voyez que je vous fais peur toujours pas
bon juge fois ma mère de mes propres
yeux prendre le morceau de fromage
il me les suis j'étais resté dans mon
lit béchir je sais la retrouver ma mère
et je lui dis maman tu es vraiment
vraiment vraiment pas dictateur et voilà
comment un autre mythe s'est envolé
c'est pourtant ça il faut rentrer
plusieurs fois faisant semblant de
ranger quelque chose pour s'assurer que
son enfant dort profondément avant de
passer à l'acte
ce film est qu un petit conseil quand je
pense à tout le fromage de mes parents
bouffer aux légumes en mai vous savez la
fidh que j'ai préféré la fête de saint
nicolas
vous connaissez cette fête à l'école mes
collègues ne la fait pas c'est une
tradition orthodoxe qui dit que cinq
fois lors pas dans une maison pour
remplir bas les bottes des enfants dès
ce lundi
du chocolat et des bonbons discovery en
tout cas pour ceux qui sont sages pour
sa petite qui a lieu dans la nuit du 5
au 6 décembre date donc réparer ses
chaussures
je détestais le times et chaussures et
j'avais pour habitude m
j'avais il a à chaque fois je
m'arrangeais à ce que mon père machines
des nouvelles
je vous avais dit que je suis coquilles
j'aime hépatique de trop fort j'essaie
de mettre plusieurs chaussures avec mon
nom devant mes parents ne laissez jamais
une année quand pourrait-il que je
n'avais pas vu trop sage
je me demande pourquoi j'ai aussi rue
saint martin est tout beau pour que je
me rappelle que je dois changer de
comportement c'est avant tout contact
avec saint nicolas pour nous éduquer
mais je ne sais pas qui fait vraiment
seul voilà qu'ils nous apportent toutes
les bonnes choses
ou si c'est les parents je n'ai pas
encore découvert mais je me doute mais
aussi nul de grandir on découvre le
monde avec des mensonges comme c'était
bien d'être encore un petit enfant
j'avais encore de la magie mais dites
moi comment nous les enfants qu on
croire en vous et bien moi anna disant
je décide encore de croire à la magie
pour faire plaisir aux autres
si des moments précieux là une fois par
an et qu'on fait ta famille c'est génial
tout ça les cloches les cadeaux et dit
tout c'est que du bonheur tout ça est
bien ce bonheur là moi je le veux j'y
crois
[Applaudissements]